LENGTHY NHL  AND HE'LL NEED THE
SEASON TOUST SEEMS TO
FIND THIS KID.
AND HE KNOWS WIDE OF THE
NET BY TO GO D-1 THAT.
I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT A LOT
OF THINGNG
ON TRACK.
SEE HIM GET TO THAT OPEN AREA.
THEY'RE TIED ATOP THE NOW WATCHS
HERE WITH SEIDER.
VERY INTEREST CENTER.
THEIR LEADING SCORER IN GOALSOR
HERE IS LARKIN.  MAN ON THE
LEFT SIDE, AND THEN THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW, DOWN.
THE FLYERS KEEP IT IN AT THE
LINE AND CONNECTING.
AND ABLE RISTOLAINEN TO  SURE,
BRUINS AND THE BRO
HIS SECOND.
NIGHT A A
FOR YORK, MAKES THE SHOT. .
JOINING IN THE  TO GETTING WITH.
>> THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF ROAD
COMING UP.
ST. LOUIS, COLORADODO THE NET
IF YOU EVEN TRY ANYMORE.  COULD
THE PUCK BY SUNDQVIST, NEW FOR
NUMBER 70, OSKAR SUNDQVIST.
LEFT HIS
.
>> Mickey: